j'ai cherché quelque chose de précieux
pour voler et le revendre et j'ai trouvé
monsieur la victime et je l'ai volé j'ai
son téléphone mais j'ai j'ai rien j'ai
pas fait de mal à personne on a entendu
notre mise en cause on a notre prévenu
on a entendu Riad victime Monsieur le
Procureur c'est toi qui va demander
aussi une une sanction tu vois si tu la
juges coupable en prenant du recul
est-ce que tu regrettes ce que tu as
fait non
ok ah
pour moi c'est une
amende qu'on a retrouvé
téléphone alors là c'est simplifié parce
que c'est une fausse bien sûr c'est une
fausse robe d'audience on a appris pas
mal de choses enfin moi personnellement
en tout cas comme par exemple le
préjudice moral je connaissais pas surci
je savais pas exactement ce que ça
voulait dire fa c'est bien parce que
grâce à ça tu peux te cultiver par
exemple moi avant je pensais vraiment
que c'était juste juste un jugement
genre avec un juge et la victime et
l'accusé bah si je fais une bêtise bah
je sais
que je vais pas en faire et bah je sais
comment ça marche c'est pas forcément
prison quand tu es jugé tu saveis avec
les les draps qui sont clissés et vous
avez la ver qu'est-ce que ça peut
vouloir dire ce principe de neutralité
en
[Musique]
faux comprendre le sens des règles que
qu'il y a un sens d'éducation et de
répression éventuellement c'est
important et puis ça leur permet de de
voir aussi l'échelle des sanction qu'on
est d'abord sur des avertissements des
mesures éducatives on fait beaucoup au
collège des reconstitutions de tribunaux
pour enfants qui sont lié en fait à des
thématiques justement qui vont les
toucher ça va être le vol le harcèlement
scolaire les violences volontaires
devant un établissement
scolaire
justeou cont aette
personne ce que j'ai bien aimé c'est les
rôles donc moi j'étais la présidente au
début c'était un peu difficile mais
avant de se mettre dans le
personnage on s'est beaucoup entraîné
pour plus tard moi je dis oui c'est
important déjà connaître mes droits
et ça évite de de faire n'importe quoi
dans la vie de tous les jours je
voudrais bien faire policier donc
apprendre la justice la base un peu
c'est je trouve ça un peu normal pour
moi ce sont des élèves étiquetés en
grande difficulté scolaire et pour nous
le fait qu'une juriste intègre la enfin
Vienne intervenir en secpa c'est quelque
chose déjà de nouveau et qui a
valorisé grandement nos
[Musique]
élèves